This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. You can picture her there. Line on her stomach and the dirt. Arcing her camera up towards the building. Tilting the frame so that the stark rectilinear building transforms into a striking asymmetric composition. You can see her taking her time with this photo. Adjusting the focus and the exposure.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。你可以想象她当时的场景。趴在肚子上，贴着地面。将相机向上对准那栋建筑。倾斜取景框，使那栋线条硬朗的直线条建筑变成了一个引人注目的不对称构图。你可以看到她在这张照片上花了很多时间。调整对焦和曝光。
She releases the shutter, impressing the negative image onto a glass plate. 90 years later, this photograph by Lucia Maholi is one of the most famous images of the German art school known as the Bauhaus. Bau, meaning the word build in German, and house, meaning house. Mediocre German and house meaning house. Mediocre German speaker, Sam Greenspan. The Bauhaus was founded by architect Walter Gropius in 1919. The school sought to fuse art with industrialization, to use new ideals of modernism to create beautiful, functional things,
她按下快门，将负片影像印在玻璃底片上。90年后，露西亚·莫霍利（Lucia Moholy）拍摄的这张照片成为了德国包豪斯（Bauhaus）艺术学院最著名的影像之一。“Bau”在德语中是建造的意思，“house”是房子的意思。德语水平一般的山姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）。包豪斯由建筑师沃尔特·格罗皮乌斯（Walter Gropius）于 1919 年创立。该学院旨在将艺术与工业化融合，利用现代主义的新理念来创造美丽、功能强大的物品，
which could be mass produced for the betterment of society. In the beginning of the Bauhaus rose from the ashes of World War I, and there was a very hopeful, very utopian period of craftsmen and artists all creating together. This is Robin Schulten-Fry. I teach architectural design history at the Courtauld Institute of Art in London, but I'm American. The Bauhaus was a magnet for European designers, architects, and artists of all kinds in the early 20th century,
这些物品可以批量生产，以促进社会的发展。包豪斯诞生于第一次世界大战的废墟之中，那是工匠和艺术家们共同创作的一个充满希望、高度乌托邦的时期。这是罗宾·舒尔滕-弗雷（Robin Schuldenfrei）。我在伦敦考陶德艺术学院（Courtauld Institute of Art）教授建筑设计史，但我是一个美国人。在 20 世纪初，包豪斯吸引了来自欧洲各地的设计师、建筑师和各类艺术家，
many of whom would go on to achieve international acclaim. The photographer, Lucia Maholi, did not become one of those famous artists. She joined the Bauhaus in 1923, but not as a teacher or as a student. Her husband, Lázló Maholi Na Naj, had been hired onto the faculty of the Bauhaus. in 1923, but not as a teacher or as a student. Her husband, Lázló Maholi Na and her husband, Lázló Maholi Na and her husband, Lázló Maholi Na and her husband, Lázló Maholi Na was expected of her, which was to do some kind of work that would help fulfill the mission of the school. Unpaid, of course.
其中许多人后来获得了国际声誉。摄影师露西亚·莫霍利并没有成为那些著名的艺术家之一。她于 1923 年加入包豪斯，但不是作为老师或学生。她的丈夫拉斯洛·莫霍利-纳吉（László Moholy-Nagy）于 1923 年被包豪斯聘为教员，但不是作为老师或学生。她的丈夫拉斯洛·莫霍利-纳吉，她的丈夫拉斯洛·莫霍利-纳吉，她的丈夫拉斯洛·莫霍利-纳吉，她的丈夫拉斯洛·莫霍利-纳吉当时对她的期望是，做一些有助于实现学校使命的工作。当然，是无偿的。
Lucia had some training in photography. She had the darkroom skills and she had really excellent technical skills of the period. So Lucia became a kind of in-house documentarian for the Bauhaus. She made portraits of the people there, of the things that they made, and of the architecture of the school itself. Walter Gropius designed the school's campus in Desau, and those buildings became a major theme of Lucy's work. She photographed the workshops,
露西亚受过一些摄影训练。她具备暗房技能，并且拥有那个时期非常出色的技术。因此，露西亚成了包豪斯内部的专属记录者。她为那里的人们、他们制造的物品以及学校本身的建筑拍摄肖像。沃尔特·格罗皮乌斯设计了学校位于德绍（Dessau）的校园，这些建筑成为了露西亚作品的主题。她拍摄了车间、
the dormitories, the master's houses. She said about showing the spaces where these new methods and philosophies of design were being made. You can see the way in which Lucy's photographs of Walter Gropius' architecture express the same ideas that he wanted to express in the architecture itself, and this is not by chance. Lucia's photography, like Gropius' architecture, is all about clarity and simplicity of form. It is utilitarian, documenting the world as it is, and it's also beautiful,
宿舍、大师住宅。她致力于展现这些新的设计方法和哲学诞生的空间。你可以看到，露西亚对沃尔特·格罗皮乌斯建筑的照片，完美表达了他希望在建筑本身中表达的思想，这绝非偶然。露西亚的摄影，就像格罗皮乌斯的建筑一样，追求形式的清晰与简洁。它是实用的，记录着真实的世界；它也是美丽的，
reveling in clean lines and stark contrast, and it's also beautiful, reveling in clean lines and stark contrast, and it's minimal showing only what's needed and nothing more. From the dark room in her and Las Los home on the Bauhaus campus, Lucia amassed a collection of five or six hundred photographs, and she couldn't have known then the impact that these images would have on the built world or on her own life. The Bauhaus aspired to lift society up out of the wreckage of World War I and into a new world of rationalism, beauty, good art and good design, to bring its brand of utopianism into the world at large. But for all their efforts, the world did not become more utopian.
沉醉于简洁的线条和鲜明的对比中；它还是极简的，只展示必需之物，不多一丝一毫。在位于包豪斯校园内她和拉斯洛家中的暗房里，露西亚积累了五六百张照片，当时她不可能知道这些影像会对建筑世界或她自己的人生产生多大的影响。包豪斯渴望将社会从第一次世界大战的废墟中拯救出来，带入一个理性、美丽、好艺术和好设计的新世界，将其实际的乌托邦主义带给全世界。但尽管他们付出了种种努力，世界并没有变得更加乌托邦。
The National Socialist government put the Baja's under increasing pressure. In 1933, it was closed down by the Nazis. Many members of the Baja's were forced to flee immediately because they were Jewish or because they were involved in very left radical politics and they had to go. Amidst all the turmoil of the Nazis raised a power, Lazlo and Lucia had separated. Lucia started dating a Communist Party member of Parliament. One day in 1933, he was arrested in Lucia's apartment while she was out.
国家社会主义政府对包豪斯施加了越来越大的压力。1933年，包豪斯被纳粹关闭。许多包豪斯成员被迫立即逃亡，因为他们是犹太人，或者因为他们参与了激进的左翼政治，他们不得不离开。在纳粹掌权的动荡之中，拉斯洛和露西亚分居了。露西亚开始与一名共产党议员约会。1933年的一天，他在露西亚的公寓里被捕，当时露西亚外出不在。
So she was not able to return to her apartment because she had to fear that she was arrested immediately too. Somebody told her, don't get back to your apartment. This is Ralph Zaukze. He teaches at the University of Zarbrook in Germany and he knew Lucy him a holy. She had to emigrate immediately so what she did was flee to her Czech family. So she went to Prague first and then she went to Paris via Austria via Switzerland. Eventually landing in London in 1933, Lucia had left behind nearly everything she owned, including the glass negatives of the Bauhaus. As she fled the country for an uncertain fate abroad, Lucia left the legacy of the Bauhaus
因此她无法返回公寓，因为她担心自己也会立即被捕。有人告诉她，别回你的公寓了。这是拉尔夫·扎乌克泽（Ralph Sautter）。他在德国萨尔布吕肯大学（University of Saarbrücken）教书，他认识露西亚·莫霍利。她必须立即流亡，于是她逃到了她的捷克亲戚那里。所以她先去了布拉格，然后经奥地利、瑞士去了巴黎。最终于1933年抵达伦敦。露西亚几乎抛弃了她拥有的所有东西，包括包豪斯的玻璃底片。当她为了一个不确定的未来逃离祖国时，露西亚将包豪斯的遗产
to an uncertain fate at home. Lucia weathered out the war in London. She had arrived in the city with basically nothing, and at one point lost everything. Again, when her apartment was bombed by German warplanes. But even in all the chaos of war, Lucia found ways to work. She wrote a book about the history of photography.
留给了国内一个不确定的命运。露西亚在伦敦度过了战争岁月。她到达这座城市时几乎一无所有，甚至在一次德国战机的轰炸中，她的公寓被毁，再次失去了一切。但即使在战争的混乱中，露西亚也找到了工作的方法。她写了一本关于摄影史的书。
100 years of photography, that was published by Penguin in 1939, and at the same time she was quite a successful portrait photographer for the high society in London. And for the most part, she put the Bauhaus behind her. She said to me that she didn't know that the Bauhaus was more than an episode in her life. She stopped thinking about it. At least until after the war. I suppose that in 1946 she received the MoMA catalogue of 1938. That must have been the first hint for her. Back in 1938, completely unbeknownst to Lucia, Walter Gropius had worked with the Museum of Modern Art in New York, MoMA, to put together an exhibition on the Bauhaus.
《摄影一百年》（100 Years of Photography），于1939年由企鹅出版社出版。与此同时，她也是伦敦上流社会一位相当成功的肖像摄影师。在很大程度上，她将包豪斯抛在了脑后。她曾对我说，她当时并不知道包豪斯只是她人生中的一个小插曲。她不再去想它了。至少在战后之前是这样。我想，在1946年，她收到了1938年的现代艺术博物馆（MoMA）目录。那一定是对她的第一个暗示。早在1938年，完全在露西亚不知情的情况下，沃尔特·格罗皮乌斯曾与纽约现代艺术博物馆（MoMA）合作，筹办了一场关于包豪斯的展览。
And because the war was still going on at the time, MoMA hadn't been able to get many of the Bauhaus' objects out of Germany. And so, the exhibition was comprised mostly of photographs, images of the products they designed, the people who made them, and the buildings where they worked and lived. Images of the dormitories, the master's houses, the workshops. Photos that use interesting angles to transform stark, rectilinear structures into striking asymmetric compositions. Those photographs were published in the museum catalog,
由于当时战争仍在继续，MoMA没能将包豪斯的许多物品从德国运出来。因此，展览主要由照片组成——他们设计的产品的影像、制作它们的人的影像，以及他们工作和生活的大楼的影像。宿舍、大师住宅、车间的影像。那些运用有趣的角度，将生硬、规则的矩形结构转化为引人注目的不对称构图的照片。这些照片被发表在博物馆的目录中，
the book that accompanied the exhibition. She would have seen her own photographs, but not her name. The 1938 Momma catalog and other catalogs and books coming out from the US do not credit her. Again, historian Robin Schultan-Fry. She also begins to see new articles that mention the Bauhaus that are illustrious good reproductions of her photographs. Following World War II, there was a surge of interest in the Bauhaus.
也就是伴随展览出版的书籍。她会看到自己的照片，却没有看到自己的名字。1938年的MoMA目录以及美国出版的其他目录和书籍都没有署上她的名字。历史学家罗宾·舒尔滕-弗雷再次说道。她还开始看到提及包豪斯的新文章，里面插有她照片的精美复制品。二战结束后，人们对包豪斯的兴趣高涨。
All of their ideas about rationalism and modernism had caught on among post-war architects and designers. More and more books and articles about the Bauhaus were getting published, and Lucia's photographs kept getting circulated. And the qualities seem to be better than you'd expect from duplications of old prints. Lucia begins to think that, just maybe, her collection of five by seven-inch glass negatives might have made it through the war after all. And she begins to think, or to sense, that her negative might have somehow survived, so she starts to try to get her negatives back.
他们关于理性主义和现代主义的所有理念都在战后建筑师和设计师中流行开来。关于包豪斯的书籍和文章越来越多地出版，露西亚的照片也不断被广泛传播。而且照片的质量似乎比你对旧版复制品的预期要好。露西亚开始觉得，也许，她那五乘七英寸的玻璃底片收藏真的熬过了战争。她开始认为，或者感觉到，她的底片可能以某种方式幸存了下来，于是她开始试图找回自己的底片。
Lucia's first move is to write to her ex-husband, Lazlo, who had since emigrated to America with his second wife, Sebel. Lucia asks if he had any clues about where the negatives she had left behind might have ended up. Sebel tells her that they in fact left these cumbersome negatives in Gropius' house, in Gropius' basement. Gropius, completely unbeknownst Lu Lucia, had actually taken her negatives with him to the U.S. when he had emigrated more than a decade earlier.
露西亚的第一步是写信给她的前夫拉斯洛，他后来带着第二任妻子西贝尔（Sibyl）移民到了美国。露西亚询问他是否知道她遗留下的底片最终落在了何处。西贝尔告诉她，他们实际上把这些笨重的底片留在了格罗皮乌斯的房子里，也就是格罗皮乌斯的地下室里。完全在露西亚不知情的情况下，格罗皮乌斯在十多年前移民美国时， faktisk 实际上把她的底片一起带到了美国。
Likely because he had friends who were higher-ups in the Nazi party, and so when Gropius left Germany, he didn't have to flee in a hurry. He was able to carefully pack up his belongings. Lucia's heavy, fragile glass negatives among them and bring them with him to Harvard, where he recently got a job. Lucy erites to Gropius. These negatives are irreplaceable documents, which could be extremely useful, now more than ever.
很可能是因为他在纳粹党内有高层朋友，所以格罗皮乌斯离开德国时并不需要匆忙逃亡。他得以仔细打包自己的行李，露西亚沉重而易碎的玻璃底片也在其中，并把它们带到了他刚获得教职的哈佛大学。露西亚写信给格罗皮乌斯。这些底片是不可替代的文献，现在比以往任何时候都更加有用。
Walter Gropius writes back. Long years ago in Berlin, you gave all these negatives to me. You will imagine that these photographs are extremely useful to me and that I have continuously made use of them. So I hope you will not deprive me of them." Lucia responds to Gropius, saying, basically, I never gave you my negative. Surely you did not expect me to delay my departure in order to draw up a formal contract, stipulating date and conditions of return?
沃尔特·格罗皮乌斯回信了。“多年前在柏林，你把所有这些底片都交给了我。你可以想象，这些照片对我极为有用，我一直在使用它们。所以我希望你不要剥夺我对它们的拥有权。”露西亚回应格罗皮乌斯说，基本上，我从未把底片交给你。你当然不会指望我为了起草一份规定归还日期和条件的正式合同而延迟离开吧？
No formal agreement could have carried more weight than our friendship. It is this friendship I have always relied on, and which also I am now invoking. But when invoking friendship didn't work, Lucia hired a lawyer, who wrote to Gropius, that his holding on to Lucia's negatives was like a firefighter saving a house and then claiming ownership of all the stuff inside.
没有任何正式协议的分量能重于我们的友情。正是这份友情，我一直依赖着，现在我也在呼唤它。但当呼唤友情不管用时，露西亚雇了一名律师，律师写信给格罗皮乌斯，称他霸占露西亚底片的行为，就像一个消防员救了一栋房子，然后宣称屋里所有东西都归他所有。
But still, Gropius was not giving them back. Gropius did never anything for anybody, except for himself. He didn't help her. He wrote very kind letters, said yes, yes. We have to think about it. We have to think about it. We have to think about it, and he did nothing. We have to think about it, we have to think about it, we have to think about it, and he did nothing.
然而，格罗皮乌斯依然没有把它们还回来。格罗皮乌斯从不为任何人做任何事，除了他自己。他没有帮她。他写了非常亲切的信，说“好的，好的。我们需要考虑一下。我们需要考虑一下。我们需要考虑一下”，然后他什么也没做。我们需要考虑一下，我们需要考虑一下，我们需要考虑一下，而他什么也没做。
This whole argument raises the question of who owns the image of a building. Intellectual property law on photography has evolved over the years, and it still varies by country. But generally, if you take a picture of a two-dimensional thing, like a painting, it doesn't show any artistry on your part, and therefore you have no claim to the ownership of that image. But if you take a picture of a three-dimensional thing, like a building, you're making decisions about position, angle, lighting, framing, you're not just reproducing what's quote-unquote really there, you're making something entirely new. And so generally, copyright on those images, that is not just the negatives, but also the prints that Gropius would have been making from them. Legally, that all belonged to Lucia. In any case, Gropius kept making prints, kept publishing them, kept circulating her representations,
整个争论引发了一个问题：究竟谁拥有建筑的影像？摄影的知识产权法多年来一直在演变，并且因国家而异。但总的来说，如果你拍摄一个二维的东西，比如一幅画，它并没有表现出你个人的艺术创造力，因此你无权声称拥有该影像的所有权。但如果你拍摄一个三维的东西，比如一栋建筑，你在位置、角度、光线、构图上做出了决定，你不仅仅是在复制所谓的“真实存在”，你是在创造全新之物。因此，通常情况下，这些影像的版权——不仅是底片，还包括格罗皮乌斯用它们冲洗出来的照片——在法律上，全部属于露西亚。无论如何，格罗皮乌斯一直在冲洗照片，一直在发表它们，一直在传播她的影像，
kept telling the story of the Bauhaus through Lucia's photography. Architecture is, in many ways, understood and consumed through photography. We don't get to see most of the world's iconic buildings. We see pictures of those buildings. And this turned out to be especially true of the Bauhaus buildings. Because after the start of the Cold War, the West's access to the Bauhaus campus was cut off by the iron curtain. Even in East Germany, it was incredibly difficult to photograph these buildings.
一直在通过露西亚的摄影讲述包豪斯的故事。在许多方面，建筑是通过摄影被理解和消费的。我们无法亲眼看到世界上绝大多数标志性建筑。我们看到的是这些建筑的照片。包豪斯的建筑尤其如此。因为冷战爆发后，西方进入包豪斯校园的通道被铁幕切断了。即使在东德，拍摄这些建筑也极其困难。
Yes, because there was no possibility of visiting them properly, and there was absolutely no chance of taking a photograph of them. I've been there for the first time in my life in the 1970s. I went to Dessau, And whenever I took off my camera, somebody came up and said, no, you can't photograph here because the Bauhaus buildings at that time were surrounded by Soviet military buildings. Photography was banned at the Bauhaus campus in Dessau from 1950 until 1980. And then later, after reunification, the buildings were altered slightly. And so, to this day, scholars like Robin Schultenfrei say that Lucia's photographs are the best representation we have of the Bauhaus.
是的，因为根本不可能好好地去参观它们，更绝对没有机会拍下它们的照片。我这辈子第一次去那里是在20世纪70年代。我去了德绍，每当我拿出相机，就会有人走过来对我说：“不，你不能在这里拍照”，因为当时的包豪斯建筑周围都被苏联军事建筑包围着。从1950年到1980年，德绍的包豪斯校园一直禁止拍照。后来，在两德统一后，这些建筑略有改动。因此，直到今天，像罗宾·舒尔滕弗雷这样的学者仍然认为，露西亚的照片是我们拥有的对包豪斯最好的呈现。
In a way, it's like those photographs are the Bauhaus. And so even the slides that I myself was taught about the Bauhaus in the 1990s, many of them were still these black and white images because they are such good quality. was taught about the Bauhaus in the 1990s. Many of them were still these black and white images because they are such good quality. After years of legal disputes, Lucien Maholi finally succeeded in getting nearly 300 of her negatives back.
从某种意义上说，这些照片就如同包豪斯本身。因此，甚至我在20世纪90年代学习包豪斯时所看到的幻灯片，许多仍然是这些黑白影像，因为它们的质量实在是太好了。我在20世纪90年代学习包豪斯时看到过。其中许多仍然是这些黑白影像，因为它们的质量实在是太好了。经过多年的法律纠纷，露西亚·莫霍利终于成功地追回了近300张底片。
But it was in a sense too late for her. And so I think that part of the story is unfortunate. Lucien Maholi died in 1989. Her negatives went to the Bauhaus archive in Berlin. And it's from Lucie's photos that architects and designers drew inspiration to rebuild the post-war world. People who rebuilt Europe drew on the ideas of the Bauhaus. They looked to its modern, rectilinear, asymmetric architecture as
但从某种意义上说，对她来说已经太迟了。所以我觉得故事的这部分令人遗憾。露西亚·莫霍利于1989年去世。她的底片交给了柏林的包豪斯档案馆。正是在露西亚照片的启发下，建筑师和设计师们汲取了重建战后世界的灵感。重建欧洲的人们借鉴了包豪斯的理念。他们将其现代、直线、不对称的建筑视为
a counter to the buildings that the Nazis had made. Fascism had used this kind of neoclassical aesthetic. Court houses that were built in the post-war period in America, post offices. These buildings were all built in the modern style. And this is where the modern style does finally take off. Our modern world owes a debt to the Bauhaus, and the Bauhaus owes a debt to Lucien Maholi, whether anyone knows her name or not. But we should know it. Today, about 90 prints of Lucien Maholi's Bauhaus photography are housed at the Bush Rising
对纳粹建造的建筑的一种反击。法西斯主义曾采用这种新古典主义美学。美国战后时期建造的法院、邮局。这些建筑都建于现代风格。现代风格也正是在这里最终腾飞。我们的现代世界亏欠包豪斯一份情，而包豪斯亏欠露西亚·莫霍利一份情，不管有没有人知道她的名字。但我们应该知道。今天，露西亚·莫霍利大约90幅包豪斯摄影作品收藏在哈佛大学的
Museum at Harvard. They were donated by Walter Gropius and are considered part of his archive. But the museum has, over time time actually been going through this archive, and crediting Lucia on photos known to be hers. Like the photo that Lucia took lying on the ground, pointing her camera up towards the Bauhaus building in Dessa. So we're looking at a photo from around 1926, a gelatin silver print.
布什-赖辛格博物馆（Busch-Reisinger Museum）。它们由沃尔特·格罗皮乌斯捐赠，被视为其档案馆的一部分。但随着时间的推移，博物馆实际上一直在梳理这个档案馆，并将已知的属于露西亚的照片署上她的名字。比如露西亚趴在地上、将相机向上对准德绍包豪斯建筑的那张照片。所以我们现在看到的是一张大约1926年的照片，一张明胶银盐照片。
It's a kind of worms-eye view, so we're looking up at this glass curtain wall, and we're looking into the workshops of the Bauhaus. Rob Weasonberger is a fellow at Harvard who works on their Bauhaus collection. The backside of the photo says in German in purple ink, photo, Lucia Moroli, desao, Ona e laubnis, reputusion verboten. Without permission, reproduction is for voting, it's not allowed, not permitted. This was the intellectual property of Lucille Moholi.
这是一种俯视的视角，或者是虫视视角，所以我们正抬头看着这面玻璃幕墙，我们正看着包豪斯的车间。罗布·韦森伯格（Rob Weasonberger）是哈佛大学的一名研究员，负责处理他们的包豪斯收藏。照片背面用紫色的墨水用德语写着：“照片，露西亚·莫霍利，德绍，未经许可，禁止翻印”。未经许可，不得复制，这是不允许的，不被允许的。这是露西亚·莫霍利的知识产权。
Yeah. 99% invisible was produced by the Swiss government. The government has been able to produce a lot of things that are not allowed to be allowed to be allowed. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Sam Greenspan, which reviewed self-catering angle Kurt Colstead, Avery Truffleman, Emmett Fitzgerald, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Sarah Borey at the University of Edinburgh, whose research on Lucium Holy got us started on this story.
是的。99% Invisible由瑞士政府制作。（笑声）政府已经能够制作出许多不允许被允许被允许的东西。本周的 99% Invisible 由山姆·格林斯潘制作，参与审核的有库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Kohlstedt）、艾弗里·特拉夫曼（Avery Truffelman）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）以及我罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢爱丁堡大学的萨拉·博雷（Sarah Boree），她对露西亚·莫霍利的研究让我们得以开始这个故事。
Thanks also to Jeffries Hatinik, Gloria Ferris, Sririba Quadrivi, Yantigi, and Mike Wolf. Anne Wouten was the voice of Luci Mahaoli and Sherefusev played Walter Grobius. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-LW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. Um, Roman Mars says that if there's a revolving door and you use the one next to it that isn't revolving then you're a monster Because they're so efficient and great. Can I can I ask you a question Justin? I've been meaning to ask you this for a while
还要感谢杰弗里斯·哈蒂尼克（Jeffries Hatinik）、格洛丽亚·费里斯（Gloria Ferris）、斯里里巴·夸德里维（Sririba Quadrivi）、扬蒂吉（Yantigi）和迈克·沃尔夫（Mike Wolf）。安·乌顿（Anne Wouten）是露西亚·莫霍利的配音，谢尔夫·乌瑟夫（Sheref Usev）饰演沃尔特·格罗皮乌斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的广播街（Radio Row）。嗯，罗曼·马尔斯说，如果有个旋转门，而你用了旁边那个不旋转的，那你就是个怪物，因为它们太高效、太棒了。我可以，我可以问你一个问题吗，贾斯汀？我一直想问你这个很久了
Uh-huh. Why don't you just go do a podcast with Roman Mars? If you would have me, I would love to to get over there I have a lot of good ideas for not like this show, but like this show like smart stuff. You know what I mean? Like real thinkers, not like, I can't just, it's not like this show, but like smart, like area-dite podcasting,
嗯哼。你为什么不直接去和罗曼·马尔斯一起做一个播客呢？如果你愿意的话，我很乐意去那边。我有很多好点子，不是那种秀，而是像这种秀，像聪明的东西。你知道我的意思吗？真正的思想家，不是那种，我不能只是，它不是那种秀，而是聪明的、博学的播客，
that's I feel like my true calling and where I really feel like my lights under a bush was kind of. Justin, do you want to do like a weird backdoor pilot for smart stuff with Justin and Robin right now and just like give us a topic You might discuss on smart stuff. Yeah, like that's a yeah, I'll give you an example And this would be like co-hosted by me and Roman, okay? So I'll kind of leave blank for his part No, I can do I can do Roman. No, I'm just gonna leave blanks for his parts Okay, you don't even want to hear my Roman. No, you can try later, but I'm just gonna leave blanks for his parts. Okay. You don't even want to hear my Roman You could try later, but I'm just gonna leave blanks for like
我觉得这是我真正的使命，也是我真正觉得自己才华被埋没的地方。贾斯汀，你想不想现在就和贾斯汀与罗宾一起为“聪明的事物”（Smart Stuff）做个奇怪的后门试播集，然后给我们一个你可能会在“聪明的事物”里讨论的话题？对，就像这样，对，我会举个例子，这个将由我和罗曼共同主持，好吗？所以我把他的部分留白。不，我可以，我可以演罗曼。不，我只把他的部分留白。好吧，你甚至不想听我的罗曼？不，你以后可以试试，但我只把他的部分留白。好吧。你甚至不想听我的罗曼？你以后可以试试，但我就把留白留给
Guys, it's me Roman Mars. I'm gonna steal your brother. Got him. Okay. Let's call a Grub revive so it'll go so like it's cut remember it's like an airy-dike kind of smart podcast that yeah Yeah, like a podcast where you know the host knows the word air you die. Yeah, yeah, yeah, that got Thanks so here's here's kind of what we'll go like. Okay, please Hello everybody welcome to smart stuff. I am your host Justin McRoy. I'm joined as always today by Roman Mars Hey, Justin Roman. What's smart thing are we discussing today? Well, this week I was excited to learn why there are so many tie races in swimming.
伙计们，我是我罗曼·马尔斯。我要偷走你的兄弟。抓到了。好吧。让我们叫一个 Grub Revive，这样它就会像——记住，它就像一个博学的、聪明的播客，对，对，就像一个你知道主持人知道“博学”（erudite）这个词的播客。对，对，对，太棒了。所以，这是，这是我们接下来要进行的。好的，请。大家好，欢迎来到“聪明的事物”。我是你们的主持人贾斯汀·麦克罗伊（Justin McElroy）。今天和我一起的依然是罗曼·马尔斯。嘿，贾斯汀。罗曼，我们今天讨论的聪明的事物是什么？嗯，这周我很兴奋地了解到为什么游泳比赛中有这么多的平局。
So in the Rio Games last week, there were three second place finishers with the exact same time in the men's 100 meter butterfly. Wanna know why? So most of the limit of events are measured in the thousands of a second. That's three units past the decimal point. But swimming is only measured in the hundreds of a second. And's three units past the decimal point. But swimming is only measured in the hundreds of a second.
所以在上周的里约奥运会上，男子100米蝶泳比赛中出现了三位成绩完全相同的第二名。想知道为什么吗？因为大多数限时项目都是以千分之一秒来测量的。那是小数点后三位数字。但游泳比赛只以百分之一秒来测量。那是小数点后三位数字。但游泳比赛只以百分之一秒来测量。
And the reason is because of the pool itself. It's virtually impossible to construct a swimming pool with lanes that are exactly equal. So international swimming regulations allow for a variability of up to three centimeters in length for each lane. Huh. Now this is enough of a difference that you can't guarantee that a swimmer is thousands of a second faster or that the lane is just like a centimeter shorter.
原因在于游泳池本身。要建造一个各泳道长度绝对相等的游泳池几乎是不可能的。因此，国际游泳规则允许每个泳道的长度有最多三厘米的误差。哈。现在，这个差距已经足够大，以至于你无法保证一个游泳者快了千分之一秒，或者仅仅是泳道短了一厘米。
So they drop that third digit to the right of the decimal point and only measure in the hundreds of a second. What? So when you only measure in hundreds of a second, you get a lot more Thai races. Oh. I learned that I've done spent. Well folks, that's all we have time for. I'm smart stuff today.
所以他们舍弃了小数点右边的第三位数，只用百分之一秒来测量。什么？所以当你只用百分之一秒来测量时，你会遇到更多的平局比赛。哦。我了解到我已经……好吧，各位，这就是我们今天所有的全部时间了。我是今天的“聪明的事物”。
If someone can get Roman Mars to cut out this bit of the podcast and actually try and fill in the blanks there, that would be freestyle there. My brother and my brother and me between the McRoy brothers can be heard on the Maximum Fund Network. Great job You can find this show and like the show on Facebook all of us are on Twitter, Instagram and Spotify But to find out more about this story including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% invisible
如果有人能让罗曼·马尔斯剪掉播客的这一段，并真正试着把那里的空白填上，那就太自由式了。我的兄弟和我，麦克罗伊兄弟之间的节目可以在 Maximum Fun 网络上收听。干得好！你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并点赞，我们所有人都在 Twitter、Instagram 和 Spotify 上。但要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，包括酷炫的照片和链接，并收听 99% Invisible 的所有单集，
You must go to 99mpi.org. Radio Tapio. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你必须访问 99mpi.org。Radio Tapio. 你还 没有 评论 对于 这个 片段。 点击 转录 中的 任何 句子 来 留下 评论。